Clouds amaze
A tangle
thread,
servers spin
inside
your head.
But a new dawn breaks,
Thorsten ons will show the key to build
and run
effortlessly.
to
Going
Innovate.
Spin it up. The future's bright.
Microservices
taking flight.
Thorsed and hunts, I'll show the key to
build and run
Hello, and welcome back to the Rawkode Academy.
This is Rawkode Live, the show where we
take a look at cool open source projects
in the cloud native space.
Today, we're gonna take a look at Fermion
Spin
but through a slightly different lens based on
some of the announcements they made just last
week at KubeCon.
Guiding us today is
Thurston Hands. Welcome back. How are you?
Hi, David. Thanks again for having me, and
hello, everybody on the stream.
Yeah. Always an absolute pleasure. For anyone who
hasn't caught us, you know, streaming together before,
could you just tell people who you are
and what you're up to?
Yep.
As David already mentioned, my name is Thorsten.
I work as a senior cloud advocate with,
Fermion,
where I mainly,
you know, am on streams,
write technical docs,
blogs,
or,
help developers
taking our products and services and our open
source projects to build software,
for
the upcoming future, right, for the next
decade, maybe. Yeah.
Awesome. Thank you.
And, you were at KubeCon last week on
the Vermeion booth talking about all the wonderful
things that the team have been up to.
So I know there's a number of announcements.
Do you wanna give us the the quick
rundown of what Fermion has been doing in
the last couple of months?
Yeah. Sure. So, yeah, the both of us,
were in, in in London for KubeCon EU.
And, yeah, as David mentioned, we we, had
a booth there and we introduced,
Fermion Wasm functions,
which is basically a fully managed hosted service
that we provide on top of Akamai's global
connected network.
So we took
like over the last couple of months,
we we took the way how we run
SpinApps
in dense
and available
fashion
and
put that together with
Akamai's globally distributed network
and locations
that they have around the globe
to,
you know, basically provide a service where we
as developers can
just take our spin apps, deploy them there,
and we don't have to care about nitty
gritty details like
selecting a region. Right? So apps are always
available and requests
are routed to the closest data center depending
on from
where the request is hitting
the app,
which is basically in a nutshell,
what Fermion Wasm functions is and what we
were,
working on,
the last couple of months.
Yeah. I think that
the understated thing about this, right, is like,
you know, anyone who has watched more than
one video on this channel knows I love
WebAssembly and building applications with this pattern. And
I always talk about the performance characteristics
of shipping WebAssembly. Right? When we start a
container,
we're measuring it in hundreds of milliseconds,
typically.
However, when we're measuring WebAssembly,
we're measuring in nanoseconds before that thing is
actually returning some data back to the user.
And, you know, the not the problem with
Fairmair Cloud, I don't wanna frame it in
that way, but Fairmair on Cloud, I believe
was like single region for the entirety of
this kind of, you know, cloud
life,
which means you have to fight the latency.
If that user is in Australia, if they're
in Asia, if they're in Europe, you don't
really know where that server is and you
could be measuring it in fifty milliseconds or
we could be measuring it in three hundred
milliseconds,
which is not the end of the world,
especially when WebAssembly is fast. However,
when you partner with Akamai, who probably have
one of the biggest networks in the world,
we're now getting this double whammy of, well,
we're gonna get that first bay or that
we're gonna get that latency down to an
absolute minimum and then the runtime and the
execution of that WebAssembly binary
is then equally fast. And then it's like,
who doesn't want that? Like, that is just
the absolute ideal scenario
for anyone that wants to ship
and have their users be happy on a
performance level at least. You know, you still
gotta write good code. Right? You know, we
can't teach people everything. But when you remove
that infrastructure component and that networking component,
I mean, that's a win. I I mean,
hands down, that is absolute win. I was
so thrilled to see this announcement. So
Yeah. Yeah. So basically how we phrased it,
we,
you know, we married the fastest fastest serverless
compute with the fastest network available
to to provide, like, lowest latency for execution.
Right?
Of of serverless of serverless workloads here.
Yeah. And the cool thing is,
for us as developers,
nothing changes. Right? We can still use
Spin to for creating WebAssembly
workloads,
or you can create them using different tool
chains as long as they align with Wazi
incoming HTTP handler, for example, right,
to build apps and deploy them there.
However,
as always, we are super keen to deliver
a great developer experience
and,
you know, extended the spin CLI to make
it aware of that new Fermian functions
service,
where you can deploy your apps. You can,
you know, inspect all the apps running on
your account and,
you know, different, like, inner loop concerns are
obviously addressed,
by default. Yeah.
Awesome.
So do you wanna give us a bit
of a rundown on what is you're gonna
be walking us through today? I mean, I
think we've all got a pretty good idea
based on what we're talking about. But, yeah,
what are you gonna be showing us how
to achieve today?
Sure.
So can
You want me to jump over to the
screen share? Yeah. That will be great. Alright.
You are now live. Take it away, Thorsten.
Okay. Cool. Thank you. So what we're looking
at right now is basically the announcement post.
I think we can put that link in
in the show notes later on,
which is,
you know, giving you an, you know, an
overview of what Fermion Wasm function is, what
it offers in more detail.
Obviously, as always,
we try to provide
best in class documentation.
And if you're familiar with what we do,
with Spin and
SpinCube,
c or the CNCF projects we, contributed.
We have obviously reworked our website to make
it a little bit, like, clearer where to
start. Right? So as a developer, you obviously
start with building apps. But at some point
in time, you wanna deploy and run them.
And there is right now a new section
over here,
fermion WASN functions,
which, you know, gives you all like details
about how to do x, y, and z
within fermion wasn't functions.
But also there is the request access button
because right now it's in preview and we
have to or we let people in once
you, you know, request access to the service.
So that's a great resource where you can
find samples,
tutorials,
you know, guiding the you as a developer,
through the process of building your apps and
getting them deployed to Fermion Wasm functions and
also some like,
let's say,
more details about how this works. And I
think that's a good starting point to to
become a little bit more
technical.
Right?
So our service comes with,
with its own registry.
Right? So
as for
like more than a year or
more than a year, yes. I think we,
we stick to OCI
artifacts
as distributable units for spin ups.
So if you build a spin up and
you wanna distribute that, you always end up
with an OCI artifact that is pushed to
some sort of OCI registry. So basically a
registry that implements the Docker registry two dot
0 standard.
And, yeah, we provide one as part of
Fermion Wasm functions,
which basically
receives your workload
and ensures
that it is deployed
across the globe. And as soon as all
the regions report back that the app is
up and running,
We register
a sub domain name for you with an
HTTPS certificate so that you can immediately
invoke or send requests to your workload.
Or you can if you use or if
you are already using Akamai products, you can
integrate them with existing Akamai products. Right? That's
possible. So to route through a property,
how it is called in Akamai
to your fermion wasn't functions.
On the back end side,
nothing changed. Right? So you can still interact
with databases,
with key value stores.
And again, we provide as part of our
service offering a globally distributed
key value store that you can just use
as you're
used to use it with, Firming Cloud, for
example. Right? So it's really like an an
incarnation
at the next evolution step on how to
run,
spin apps on
a fully managed platform.
Alright. So,
what do you need to get started? I
think that's always,
the most important
information for us as developers.
So I have installed
spin on my oops. Yep. Spin
dash dash version
on my machine in the latest stable release.
That's version three dot two dot o.
And I have also
installed a new plugin that's called
AKA.
That's basically the plugin, you know, for interacting
with Fermian Wasm functions. You you see already
like familiar
sub commands like apps, manage applications,
or to deploy an app, to log in,
and so on and so forth. So we
will go through that entire
workflow,
once we have implemented an app that we
can deploy
to the service.
The most important question at this point might
be how can I get that ECA plugin?
And again, the documentation
provides a quick start where you can, you
know, find information on how to install Spin
and
how to install
the plugin, the ECA plugin that I have
already installed on my machine.
This is especially handy if you have already
spin installed on your machine or if you
installed it before we release that plugin. Right.
As always,
language specific tooling is required. So if you
want to write your apps in JavaScript, TypeScript,
you need node installed in your machine. If
you want to write your apps in Rust,
you need Rust installed with the Wasm 32
WasiP one target.
And if you wanna write your apps in
Go, then you need TinyGo installed in a
recent version. I think I've installed
let me check TinyGo
version
o
36. I think 37
is already out.
So that will also work.
But keep in mind to also upgrade your
templates because
there was a rename
of the entire Wasm 32 Wasi platforms
at the beginning of the year.
So for Rust, for example, it's now called
Wasi 32 Wasi P one. And for TinyGo
there was a change as well. Right. So
if you encounter some errors
following the guide,
building the app, it chances are pretty high
that there is that you hit exactly that,
you know, change from
the underlying platform name.
But that's all we need. Right? We need
on,
the spin, installed on on the machine. We
need language specific tooling and that Akamai
or the Akka plugin.
So the service is a multi tenant
service,
which means we have to authenticate
in in some way. Right? And,
you know, we use a lot of GitHub,
so we have we use GitHub as an
authentication
provider.
So once you have requested access, you know,
and the onboarding is completed,
you can do a spin aka login over
here.
And
that is a regular device code flow over
here where I can say, I wanna authenticate
with my individual
GitHub account and then I have to grant
the CLI
the permissions to interact
with fermion wasn't functions on my behalf. Right?
So I can, can I can close that
tab right now.
And
as you can already see, it welcomes me.
And now I have access to, you know,
my account
where I can do things like obviously deploy
apps or I can simply say
apps list
to explore what's already there. And as you
can see, I played around a bit
with Fermin Wasserman's Yeah, you've got a couple.
Yeah, and I cleaned up a couple of
them already before
the stream.
So, yeah, you get like, you know, the
list of apps deployed to your account. And
as as you mentioned, David,
the both of us were at KubeCon.
So let's take this one for example.
You can do a spin archive
apps info.
I think it was without a dash. Yeah.
It was without a dash.
And you can see
that I deployed. However, never invoke the app.
No. I did not invoke it in the
last seven days.
So I deployed an app there
that is available at this URL and it
basically prints
hello world,
you know, a quick
verification
demo.
Yeah. So
I think the key point is it's a
super intuitive,
sub command to the SPIN CLI
addressing like day to day,
concerns.
And we will obviously, right now, start building
something.
And,
for those of you were on or joined
the last stream where I, ran into some
issues with the ET router in in in
TypeScript,
there are also great news,
in regards to
the HTTP
TypeScript and JavaScript
templates.
Let's say, hello,
fermion
wasm functions,
and let's edit two to be safe. I
think I have one already.
So we updated JavaScript
and TypeScript templates since, David and I were
on stream,
last time.
And the new templates allow you to choose,
from different routers because I think,
I like Hono pretty,
a lot and,
I think it's
API is super memorable
for at least to me.
And
but maybe you wanna roll without an HTTP
router. Right? That's now also possible.
So let's I like Hono as well. It's
a great little mini framework. And, you're right.
The developer experience, the API surface of it
is is slick.
Yeah. It it is it is super great,
especially, like, it's middleware APIs.
I like them,
a lot. And,
yeah, stumbled upon it couple of a while
ago and
yeah. So we updated our templates.
So that's,
also new.
So let's jump right into Hello
Fermion Wasm Functions two.
Let's open up code
and let's increase the font size a bit.
Again,
nothing,
new over here. Right? We have package JSON
like a idiomatic
an idiomatic
JavaScript or TypeScript in that case project.
However, right now the dependency
added to the project is Hono instead
of Ity. But you can choose whatever,
know, which router you want.
So before diving into code, let me do
one thing. Let's do a quick spin build
because spin build also runs an NPM install
if that hasn't been executed in that project
to pull down the dependencies
and
which, you know, is basically,
turning on the lights to get IntelliSense
and auto completion and stuff like that in
in Versus Code.
Alright.
So the
the skeleton that we create when using Hono
is giving like, you know,
simple guidelines on how you can use capabilities
provided by Hono such as the built in
logger,
a middleware that adds a response header
and to get routes.
Right? So pretty pretty default hello world experience.
Let's let's save that as it is and
we will, you know, change that and enhance
that
during the stream.
But let's let's
let's give it a try. Right? Let's say
it's been built. So we updated couple of
yeah. I removed couple of comments. So let's
build that again.
And
now that is built, I can do the
usual spin up to test it on my
local machine.
I can curl
local host 3,000.
I get back Hello Spin and I think
if I say Hello no, not greeting me.
Let's greet David.
There you go. You get Hello David. This
time that is
if we look at the headers, we get
JSON back. In contrast, the root route was
a plain text
response.
Okay. So it works on it works on
my machine.
That's great.
We see that we get logs
provided by the Hono Logger middleware.
Let's take that app and let's deploy to
Firmin Wasm functions,
which is as easy as doing a spin
echo deploy.
And right now it's taking,
you know, the Wasm file, the spin manifest,
creates an OCI artifact,
push that to the wasm func fermion wasm
functions
registry.
And
now it's deploying the application across the globe
into all the regions that are part of
the service.
So we had a question on the chat
about that. Sure. Actually, I'm gonna bring it
in now. But Paul was asking how many
pops are there on this network? How many
regions are we deploying to?
So there's a difference between,
points of presence POPs
and,
regions.
I I'm not hundred percent confident how many
regions. Let me quickly look up.
Let me quickly look up. So
list of countries
is pretty damn long.
Try to come up with Oh, we have
over 4,200
edge points of presence on the Akamai connected
network.
And the
service is right now we operate it
not in all regions provided by Akamai.
So if I remember correctly, we're currently running
in six regions as part of the preview.
However, we are super happy to stamp out
new regions and, you know, grow during the
preview period
as well.
So I think yesterday and the day before
we,
extended and or we we added two more
regions before that we were running on four
regions.
So that's growing but obviously
once we move out or graduate out of
the current preview phase, we will distribute it
across all the date, all the regions that
we could
deploy
to.
Awesome. Thank you.
Yeah. Great
question, Paul. Sorry for not remembering
the number
from top of my head. But, yeah, it's,
more than 4,200
POPs.
Okay. So in the meantime, deployment it roughly
takes a minute or so to deploy or
to ensure that the app is deployed across
all the regions.
It happens in parallel so we expect like
the same you know time frame no matter
how many regions
participate,
or are part of the service offering.
And we end up with a
generated,
sub domain under echar.fermion.tech,
which you can obviously,
you know,
put behind
your first, or your first line of of
defense or your DNS configuration,
right, to expose it under your,
domain name. So let's curl it.
And we get a hello spin.
And I think it was hello
raw
code, let's do that.
And there we go. And we get back,
the expected result. If we
take a look at the headers right now,
oops, dash I, we
can see that
the closest one,
for me is
the European
Central region
in,
in the Akamai
cloud.
This is due to the fact that I'm
based close like 150 kilometers away from Frankfurt.
So,
yeah. If I would live like couple of
kilometers further
south,
chances would be better to end up in
a France
region because
there I'm so close to,
to the France border.
But that's like an indicator that you can
see, hey, which which region handled that particular
request.
Can you drop that URL in the the
chat for me? I'm I'm just curious. I
wanna I wanna see if I'm gonna get
EU Central or something else. Sure.
Let me copy that. And,
there we
go.
Thank you very much. Did you get it?
I I got it. Yeah. Okay. Cool.
I got Paris.
There you go. Paris.
Interesting.
Well, yeah, I guess that's a good I'm
in Scotland. So Oh, okay. That's pretty good.
Yeah. I'll take that.
There's there's another interesting header added over here.
We have that x Envoy upstream service time,
which is basically telling you,
after entering the network, the Akamai network, how
long in milliseconds did it take to process
that entire request.
And we see four
which is
that's I executed the request couple of times.
It's higher as I expected it and that's
due to the fact that the app writes
to standard out. Right? Which is always an
expensive,
action. Right?
So if you strive for best perf,
obviously,
Rust is faster
or Rust code compiled to WebAssembly.
That's the alright. The the the correct explanation
is faster than taking JavaScript or TypeScript and
compile it onto WebAssembly
because the binary does not have to, you
know, doesn't have to contain
a run time like a JavaScript run time.
So there are ways to get even lower
like to
one millisecond or less.
Okay.
Now we have that hello world deployed
and we can do spin
echo logs over here
to get like the logs that this particular
app produces.
And the,
plugin is smart enough to recognize, hey, you're
still in that folder
where you created that application.
So it can determine
the actual name of the application
by
investigating
the local, the current folder. Right? So if
I step out of this folder
and if I do a spin oops spin
echo logs it says hey there is no
spin TOML. Right? I can't find I don't
know which logs I should present.
So I can say, there's Hello KubeCon. Okay.
I don't know if that one create logs.
Fermion wasn't functions two, then I provide the
name of the app. Right. And I can,
you know, obviously also
inspect how an app behaves at run time.
If I don't have access to the source
code or if I am in a different
like corner on my on my hard disk.
Cool. So this is like super sample a
super simple hello world.
But what are like typical use cases. Right.
So we we thought about,
besides,
let's call it line of business applications.
So I don't know, crud over a database
or,
you
know,
interacting
with the key value or loading data from
a key value store. What are what are
typical use cases?
And what we created,
this is a public repository.
And again, I will post the link to
or will send the link to you, David.
This one
where,
everyone could explore
couple of samples that we created as part
of tutorials or just that we think
are super valuable for you know doing computation
close to the user
instead of, you know, routing the request around
the globe to a data center that
is has been selected.
So there are a couple of AB testing
scenarios,
traffic filtering,
blocking
requests based on users country and and stuff
like that. Right? Response header modification,
gated gated access,
so a limit access,
that's that's also pretty interesting. So imagine you
have like,
you you are
you have no embargo.
Right? And you wanna do a a hard
launch launch at at at a particular time,
then you can easily because that execution
is so fast, right, you can just say,
hey, up until
eleven,
11:59,
fifty nine
AM,
return a 04:04 and
starting at noon
just open the gate and let people in.
Right?
So there are interesting scenarios that you could
could achieve with running closer to user when
you could place computation,
yeah, with low latency instead of, the the
regular way to the data center.
Yeah. And I thought it would be great
to take one of the examples and implement
it from scratch.
So
I would say like a simple
AB testing scenario,
to return different content,
based on
a key value store. So obviously,
and I think this is super important for
like
enterprise
scenarios
or like,
you know, extending existing,
software products.
You can provide your own key value store.
Right? That could be in your cloud of
choice. That could be, I don't know, a
hosted one that you expose through your private
network.
Whatever. Right? You can provide your own, but
we also provide a globally distributed
key value store as part of the service
offering. And that's what I will use for
demonstration purposes right now.
Okay. We start again with, or let's let's
check what we have over here. Good. So
let's do a spin a new t http
t s again and I think after that
one we will do a simple rust to
illustrate that every language works.
But let's say this is the AB
key value,
AB testing
sample. Let's go that way.
Okay. We wanna respond to everything and
I like Hono, so let's stick with Hono.
And let's do a spin build again to
ensure all the dependencies are installed. Can I
ask some questions just about Sure? The setup
right now? So, you know, this is the
second time we spun up a a TypeScript
thing. And I think, you know, anyone following
along at home that wants to do this
too. What they're gonna see is one, NPM
is you and node are used by default
and webpack is used as a bundle. So
as someone who writes a lot of TypeScript
myself, there's obviously a lot of momentum now
to alternative run times. I'm talking about Dino
and Bunn,
as well as
almost
mass migration away from webpack to things like
ES build.
So my curiosity is like, okay, do I
have the options to use BUN or Deno
instead?
Can I replace Webpack?
And if I can, is this as simple
as me creating a new template and submitting
a PR? Like, how does this all work
under the hood? That's a that's a pretty
good question. So let's
take that question and go to the Spin.
Js SDK.
So,
obviously, the
JS SDK as all the all the spin
repositories
has been moved from the Fermion organization
to the spin framework organization on GitHub as
part of Spin being accepted
as a CNCF sandbox project. So that's why
there is a different URL.
And there is the Spin, JS SDK.
So
there are templates
that, you know,
are provided
that you can install
on your machine.
Obviously, you can roll your own templates.
So if we
sneak into pull requests,
there is ad support for Yarn,
which we postponed a bit because,
we brought in Hono and we did some
major refactorings
about modules modularization
that I that I will explain in a
second.
But
in regards to,
the build
tool chain and
package managers,
there is obviously
a way to, you know, customize
what happens. A spin template,
let me let me zoom in a bit,
always consists of two things. You have that
metadata file that describes what this template is
all about,
That could have like parameters.
Right? So HTTP router being the new one
over here.
And we have
there are two ways how you can create
a new component
in Spin. One is that spin new that
I did like two times right now. I
choose a template
and then basically everything
from the content folder over here will be
dumped to your
desired folder. Right?
With some, you know, replacement happening in in
template files and so and so on and
so forth.
However, there's a second way. You can always
add an additional component to an existing spin
app. And that's, you know, I think it's
valuable to understand that that's why there is
a dedicated
component
TXT,
over here that will be merged into your
existing
spin.toml.
And if we look into the package JSON,
you can see there's right now npm
npx
webpack
being executed
before
j two wasm is basically responsible for taking
the JavaScript source code that Webpack created with
our templates and,
you know, turning that into into WebAssembly.
So obviously you could like
submit a PR,
replace Webpack with ES build.
Definitely possible.
Right?
Regarding the runtime,
so
the JavaScript,
SDK
for Spin and
the underlying tools, the build tools,
so Spin framework build tools, they're responsible for
turning your JavaScript source code into WebAssembly. And
as part of that, a runtime must be
shipped or must be compiled to WebAssembly as
well.
And we are currently using Starling
Monkey,
which is a
bytecode alliance
project
that is, you know, the
runtime.
I I think it roots from SpiderMonkey the
runtime
the from from Firefox.
Right?
It in addition to other runtimes,
is
it implements all the service worker specs and
so on and so forth so that, you
know,
regular like fetch APIs work as you would
expect them to work.
Swapping out that one is
also possible,
right, as long as the desired runtime could
be turned into
Wazi or WASM
Wazi P
two compliant,
component or in a WASM WebAssembly component.
Yeah. So I don't know if Deno or
Bunn
could be turned I I haven't looked into
that, to be honest. Deno can certainly
run
and import Wasm?
But I I I don't think moving away
from Starland Monkey is a good idea. I
think that that is the right move. I
I think looking now that I understand how
this is built under the hood, if you
go back to your template one. Right? Yeah.
Really, I just need to update the build
steps in my package JSON. Like, webpack, I'm
pretty sure I can remove. Even Dino has
a bundle command, which will give me a
bundle dot j s. So Mhmm. Then I
could just run the j to BASM
and hopefully, would work. What is the responsibility
then? Sorry. I know we're getting into the
weeds of it now. What is the responsibility
of the build tools package? What is that
doing?
So that's a good question.
Top of my head, we
have to
look into that. Let me Yeah. Go take
a look.
Spin framework.
Come
on.
So the build tools, I expect them to
be good.
No, maybe it's Maybe it's on the JS
SDK. Yeah, maybe it's a yeah,
that was wrong. Maybe it's a package being
packages.
So the, yeah, there it is. Oh
yeah, it's basically wrapping
componentized
JS
and yeah.
Oh, so wrapping up with them. Yeah, it
was basically me
catching
up with like recent
modifications
right now, a talk.
So
over the past couple of months, there was
a lot of there were a lot of
improvements
to the JavaScript SDK and the JavaScript,
templates,
that happened. Right? So
our
intention was
to make spin
projects with TypeScript and JavaScript more and more
idiomatic.
Right? Couple of weeks ago you ended up
with a folder, a nitwit configuration
file that deploy that defines which which
which as web assembly interface types
words
must be imported
by your component and what's exported. Right? And
although that is super useful
at to some degree if you wanna you
know
become or implement more advanced capabilities
or to to
compose
complex
systems for multiple components.
Things like that become super important and and
and you know you wanna tailor that
maybe at some point.
But for the majority
of workloads where you wanna, you know, create
an API
or interact with as we are going to
do with key value store,
you
we wanted to have the,
project as clean and simple as possible. So
we try
we try to, you know, pack more and
more into
like dependencies
that we add to the project instead of,
having you to maintain
or to track that in your source in
your source control.
Yep. Alright.
So,
once we are here,
we
also
started
modularizing
the,
Spin SDK for JavaScript so that you can
now precisely
pick and choose different capabilities
when building Spin apps.
And which is basically what we will do
in a second.
So we created an app right over here,
the AB testing sample app. We build it.
So we downloaded and the dependencies
and we turned it into
a web assembly module.
You know, that was just me to ensure
my Versus Code is happy and I get,
you know, IntelliSense
and stuff like that. So the idea is
to implement an AB,
an AB testing
and based on key value store. So what
I have to do right now is I
do a NPM install
at spin framework
forward slash spin dash k v,
which, you know, adds that as a dependency
to my application.
And from now on,
I can use the spin,
APIs
as, you know, as I'm
used to use them.
So I can say,
over here import
k star
as k v from
add spin framework.
There we go.
And now I could start using them.
So we'll do that in a second, but
first let me do some housekeeping
over here.
Alright. So we still have the
the logger. Yeah. Let's let's have logger. Let's
stick with them and,
we wanna basically
expose
a get endpoint at root route,
which gets the context
from Honu.
And over here, we will do the following.
So
let's say
every
even
request
should return
something
different
from every odd request. That's the overall idea
of that sample. Right?
And to do that we track like every
invocation
of that
of that application.
So we can use
whole new middleware middleware for that.
So that's async.
And again, we get the context
and we get next.
Alright. So this is basically
allows us to run
code before
the
actual
handler
and then we say await,
next.
And then we can run code after the
actual
handler. And that that's what I meant at
the beginning of the stream with I really
like
their,
their middleware
syntax and the way of how to structure
your app. It it reminds me a little
bit to, you know, like aspect oriented
programming where you can take an existing application
and enhance,
your handlers or enhance your app before the
actual handler or before the handlers and after
the handlers.
I like that approach,
really much.
And I mean, a great use case here
is, like, making sure you respond to your
users or customers as quickly as possible. And
then anything that can happen after the fact,
you know, I'm thinking analytics or event processing
and stuff, you just do that after. And
then it doesn't affect that response latency.
Right. Right. There's so there are numerous numerous
use cases where this is super handy, right,
where you can send a response and keep
on computing to finalize or to, you know,
whatever. Take your bucket
of data that you collected throughout the request
but then push it to whatever back end
you you have to push it to but
already present the answer to the user.
And and we lose slightly,
something something something similar to that. Right. So
the idea the idea is to have a
counter. Right. So let's say interface
counter,
which has a count,
that's obviously a number
And we wanna store and retrieve that from
the key.
So I like to get rid of magic
strings. So let's say hits is a constant,
that's our key,
that we will use.
And let me push the code a little
bit to the upper.
So
key value as always in in spin, we
have the concept of a store. So k
v,
you can see you can open a named
store or you can open the default
store which is the store with the name
default.
So let's open the default store over here
and let's initialize the counter for now.
Counter equals
count
is zero
as count as
counter.
As as soon as the microphone is above
my keyboard,
it feels wrong. Right? It
Yeah. Every time there's a camera in my
face, my typing goes to absolute crap. It's
just it's a rule. Right? That's it. That's
how it works. That yeah. That is how
it is. That's true.
Okay. So we initialized
that counter with zero because
it could be the case that my app
has never been invoked.
Right? And I wanna use that value from
at that point.
So let's say store,
if
a value at key exists,
then we obviously wanna take that value instead.
So we can say
get JSON over here,
at position key and cast that inch to
into a counter again.
So this is basically
if,
you know,
no one execute or hit
send a request to our app, we start
with the count of zero. Otherwise, we just
take it from the key value store and
use whatever is stored in key value store.
And now we can easily pass that, you
know, count
to,
the handler before invoking it by saying, hey
context,
please set a value called cup
called count
to counter dot count.
Okay. Then we invoke our handler.
So let's implement that and that's that's pretty
straight forward. Right. We again have to load
the count,
so we can say count
count
equals
number. So we parse whatever we get,
to a number because this API returns an
any,
add position,
count.
Okay. Let's
get rid of that one as well.
Const
context.
Oh, that's rust.
Context key
equals,
and let's say count,
and let's use single quotes over there as
well. So let's use that as
the value and then we can grab that
from here and get rid of the magic
string.
Okay. So we have the count right now
as a number
and then we can easily say,
let's roll with if count,
if count,
modulo two
equals null,
then we wanna return, let's say return c
dot HTML,
h one.
Let's say even
and otherwise let's return
over
here. Right. Just a simple example.
So we have successfully
read the value from key value store. We
have implemented like the AB testing algorithm,
super fancy,
right now. So what's missing? Obviously, we somehow
have to store the value.
And this is what we wanna do after
the invocation.
But we can't simply, you know, set it
as it is. We have to increment it.
So we say counter dot count
plus, equals counter dot count plus one.
Obviously we can also use the shortcut there.
But
ultimately we call store
set JSON
and we set at position key,
we set counter.
Okay. So that's basically the implementation
of our app that we now wanna deploy
to
Fermi and Watson functions.
However, there's one thing, one important thing missing.
As always, WebAssembly has that deny by default
security mechanisms. So we can't make use of,
external resources
without
specifying that and a key value store is
no exception here.
So that happens in
the spin manifest where I can say, hey,
my AB testing
sample component
should or requires
a key value
store.
So you could request multiple
and as I use that open default method,
right, that's just
syntactic sugar
that
executes
open
default.
Right.
So that's why I have to explicitly
provide or ask
to
make use of a key value store called
default.
Okay. I think
that's ready for testing or
compiling first and then testing. Right. So it's
been built. It recognized. Okay. There was some
code change.
So there we go.
App built successfully
and spin up again.
Now I can see, okay,
you requested the default key value store.
In the case of doing a simple spin
up,
spin will take care of creating a SQL
like database for you
that acts as a key value store on
your local machine.
So let's
do our curl
local host
3,000
and we get even and we get odd
and so on and so forth. Right?
So simple key value based AB testing.
So now let's take this one and throw
it over the wall to
fermin walls and functions.
And that's again as you see us doing
a spin aka deploy.
And the same thing we saw earlier, right?
Packaging the app, distributing it, and making it
available
across the globe.
Are there questions that we can take in
those 60
I mean, I have one.
Sure. Go ahead.
Now that, you know, we've got these WebAssembly
functions on the Akamai network. Right? We've already
discussed the matters of that and the fact
that it is one of the biggest networks
in the world and you're adding new regions.
Right? So
as the Akamai CDN in front of this,
and I'm asking that because I'm curious. If
I return a cache control header on some
of these functions,
will the CDN cache that for subsequent requests?
That's a pretty good question.
And I think we were already at this
one.
Right?
I shall brought that. Right?
It's not there, right?
Yeah, there we go. Right? So we can
obviously
integrate
with the CDN which sits in front.
Alright, so can we add a cache control
header to the endpoint then?
Sure.
Let's try.
I know this is gonna then add another
sixty seconds and I'll have to think of
another question.
But let's try it. Oops. Even.
Yep.
Odd. Even. Odd. Even. Odd. Even. Odd. So
let's break that then with cache control. Let's
break it by adding cache control header. Okay.
Let me let me do one thing. Let's
let me quickly curl no. Not curling that
one.
Let me curl
this one,
with dash I.
So these are the default headers. Okay. Obviously,
we have more latency because we right now
talk to that
this to add to that key value store
right,
but yeah let's go to,
this one
and let's easily,
we can do that over here
See dot
header,
that is is that property.
Okay. So we can nope. I think we
can simply set that.
Yep.
And
what do you want? Do you want
it needs to be cache dash control.
Cache control. Okay. You'd have to set max
dash age
equals
ten for ten seconds.
Ten equals get it.
Oh, yeah. Sorry. Sure. Yeah. Makes sense. Yeah.
So that should set. Remember that's response for
twenty seconds.
Okay. So let's
do that.
Oops. Like this. Okay. Cool. So let's do
spin our card.
Do you have to build it first? Spin
build. Good
catch.
But I think
you can
easily
also use the DashBash build, the same experience
as you have for spin up or spin
deploy.
Right? So Okay. That deploys.
I've got more questions for you. Sure. So
these examples are great. Right? They're really revealing
how the Akamai integration works and the cool
things we can do and the whole new
stuff. The whole new stuff is great. Like,
that is now my default for all typescript.
I
was never a big fan of it. I
like clonal.
Now what if I need some
credentials
and configuration passed into my application? What if
I want an endpoint for, like, an s
three bucket and I also wanna pass in
the access and secret key as secrets? What
is the flow to do that? Good question.
Good question.
So
as
obviously there are sensitive and non sensitive configuration
data that you want to use within your
application.
And you can specify them as part of,
executing
SpinAccordeploy.
So there are flags where you can specify
your configuration
values and that's and the important thing is
the,
value or the configuration values are tied
to that particular deployment.
Right? Because right now I'm issuing the second
deployment
of that app. Right? And it could be
the case that I introduced
variables with that update right now that haven't
hasn't haven't been there
before.
So I think that's something if you
start adding variables to your spin app and
you wanna do spin aka deploy
variable.
You see, there are some,
I
hope not that
sensitive. No, not non sensitive variables
that I specified over here.
On the service level, obviously, everything is encrypted.
All the variables are encrypted
and only
exposed
to that particular deployment
or version of your app on your account.
Does that mean every version or every deploy
gets its own unique URL?
No.
It does not. We are currently operating
in latest
is
available at. It's always, you know, like, this
one is always pointing to the latest version.
Okay. Gotcha. Okay.
So let's try
if we broke our AP testing on purpose.
So we get even.
We get even.
We get even. We get even. Can you
add a dash I to that? We should
be able to see the cache Sure. Off
as well. Right?
Yeah. There we go. Fine.
The the funny thing is, you know, that
I bet the first request after cache expiration
will also be even because the value is
now even in in
key value store.
Well, it looks like the value should change.
Yeah. There we go. Yeah. There we go.
That's awesome. Yeah. I I didn't know if
that was gonna work, but having the Akamai
CDN sit in front of all,
that's that's super cool. I love that. Yeah.
Yeah. Okay. So we have that. We already
explored
logs. Right? So that was a spin,
aka logs. Right?
Sure. That should work. If the app write
logs, and I Mhmm. Yep. Some logs. Yeah.
Only two requests, which is exactly what I
would expect with the cache control. So, yeah.
Lovely. Yeah. Okay.
On top of that, we are obviously,
you know, adding
more and more capabilities
to the Spin AKA or to to Firm
and Wasm functions and to the
AKA
plugin that we provide.
You can generate tokens in order to do
CI CD workflows where it deploys straight from
get up actions to gear account on Mhmm.
Fermion WASM functions. I think that's,
so let me quickly give,
folks an overview of what you can expect
there, right. You can create, delete list and
regenerate
personal access tokens. What do you expect from,
you know, to
to
basically do continuous deployment?
Can I ask you another question? Is that
okay? Sure. Alright. Don't mean to cut you
off. All this stuff is what I would
expect to work with the Spin cloud plugin.
Right? Like, there's a lot of overlap here
between the ACA and the cloud. So my
curiosity is,
one, if I log in if you log
in to Fairmion Cloud, will you see your
ACA functions next to your normal functions? And
secondly, do we get all the same features
we had with Fairmion Cloud? Can I do
a custom domain on a Akamai deployment?
So both are great questions. So a, to
answer the first one, if you log into
cloud.fermion.com,
you won't see,
your workloads deployed to Fermion WASM functions.
We're
still in in preview.
Maybe there
maybe there will be a new UI. I
don't know.
I don't know yet, to be honest. I
don't know yet.
So know that you can't explore like the
Fermin Wasm functions from within Fermin Cloud because
those are two two separate like platforms.
The way how the entire like, you know,
building blocks of that service are different as
they are on on on Fermion Cloud.
And,
the other question was,
if you,
you know, what's the feature
compare comparison
or comparative to to Firming Cloud,
especially regarding,
custom domains.
For example,
our intention is
as we run on top of Akamai to
integrate
with Akamai's
services.
And
in Akamai there's a service called properties,
which basically allows you to bring
your own domain,
maybe
use
Acme or let's encrypt to
acquire an SSL certificate,
bring your own SSL certificate,
configure your
either simple or really sophisticated
routing rules,
and then, you know, route to
the fermion wasn't functions.
So that's how it is
today. That's how we designed that service to
integrate seamlessly with what's in front of
in front of our service in
Akamai.
And
yes, so slightly different as you may already
know from
or as the experience is with Fermi Cloud.
Right. But as you said, this is in
preview. There's still a lot of things to
come down the road. So, yeah, it's very
exciting to see where we are at the
moment.
Yeah. Yeah. And one part of that preview
is, we have unstable cron jobs.
So, this is under active,
development.
Right? Because, I mean,
building real world application HTTP
is could be like a great entry point
to trigger a function. But also, I mean,
maybe you wanna run something on a schedule.
Right? So And build my own status page,
my own health checks.
For example, yes.
So we try to, you know, always iterate
super fast and, you know, keep it simple
yet maintain
like the DX that we know. So creating
creating a cron job is as easy
as saying cron. Oh, there was one create
and let's say root route
cron, let's give it a name, root.
So every second
minute
send a request to the root route at
forward slash
and cron dash root is just the name
for my cron job so that I can
I
can
inspect or I can see it when
I do a cron list? And right now
the service will simply invoke that route
every second minute.
Right. So that's how it is today. We
are
obviously, you know, iterating over there and you
know, adding more and more capabilities
to
to features like for example, Cron to make
it like full fledged and, you know, bring
more and more capabilities
there.
Awesome.
Okay. So this is
cron we have deployed. Oh, we can do
a spin aker
app
apps info.
Let's do that.
So we saw, yeah,
fundamental metrics. Again,
yeah,
this is part of now trying to give
the developers some insights about how the app
behaves at runtime. That could be logs, that
could be metrics.
Right?
So
basically laying the foundation.
Cool.
There's one more thing.
The nice part, one of the nice parts
of WebAssembly is its portability,
right?
So,
we,
although we
extended
SpinCLI
by adding that,
ECA plug in and, you know, creating the
service, so the the the cloud side of
things,
we did not change anything to the SpinApps.
So SpinApps
remain like a WebAssembly component
that exports a given capability,
that imports given capabilities from the underlying run
time,
which means
we still can do things like taking the
same spin app
and say spin registry push and call that
AB testing
for one hour. So TTLSH
is like a femoral
We can browse the website in the meantime
while it's pushing.
TTLSH
is an anonymous and ephemeral docker image registry
where you can store your OCI
artifacts.
And basically the TTL is defined by the
tag that you provide when pushing
your artifact. So everyone
could right now,
you
know,
take the AB testing app in the next,
fifty nine minutes and couple of seconds
and run that on
maybe
it's all machine,
using the
dash dash from,
Yeah.
AB testing
one h.
Oh, think it no. It's not from. It's
spin
up dash dash from.
There we go. Right. So that pulls the
OCI artifact and you can do that on
your machine right now and you will end
up with the same app running on your
machine.
So
we have the app running on
for a minwasm functions.
We can run it locally using spin up.
But we can also go ahead and simply
deploy to Kubernetes.
So I have a Kubernetes cluster over here.
Let's say k get
n s for example,
that's
thirty five days old. Which one is it?
Yeah. It's an AKS cluster with SpinCube running
on top of it.
So that is SpinCube.def.
Right? That's also
it's a sub project of spin,
which means this is also CNCF,
also a part of the CNCF sandbox project,
which allows you to run your serverless workloads
on your Kubernetes cluster
right besides your containerized
workloads.
So you can,
right now, simply do a spin
cube scaffold,
scaffold
from
point to the however
I called it AB testing for one hour.
Point to the OCI artifact.
Right. And without further ado it's just printing
it to standard out so we can tailor
this. We can for example say replicas.
I want to start with 10 replicas.
I want to integrate HPA. I want to
integrate KEDA. If you have KEDA deployed to
your cluster to scale horizontally
based on how I call it contextual load.
Right?
But we we could simply say, hey deploy
this
using kubectl
apply
and take STD in. So we pipe
the
manifest
to standard in of the following command, which
is kubectl apply.
And basically in our Kubernetes cluster, we now
get a spin app
AB testing.
Let's do a wide.
This is the new one which is pulling
the image, so let's kill the old one.
K delete spin app AB spin.
So let's
k get spin app.
So there is an executor, there is an
operator
deployed to the Kubernetes cluster that watches exactly
that CRD.
I deployed one
and then the operator goes, moves on and
creates a deployment for you. Right. I specified
replica
or I removed the replica. No, I specified
replica as one. Right. That's why we see
desired one,
ready one right now.
So we see also a pod,
however,
the pod does not consist of containers instead
that's just a sub process or process
on the underlying node. Right? So there's no
container involved here.
And also the operator creates a service for
you allowing you to route
requests
to your spin apps. And if you scale
out, you know, the Kubernetes service does it's
thing to a router request to one
of the replicas.
So we can do kubectl
or no, let's say k port forward
forward
to the service or we could immediately directly
point to port as well. So AB testing,
let's say localhost 8,080
to port 80 of that port.
And now we can call curl
8,080.
And we have the same app without recompilation,
without anything
running
on an AKS cluster right now. And to
be honest, I can't remember which architecture
it
was using.
So let's check.
Oh,
I don't know if you see the architecture
there.
No. Let's do a KDescribe
node.
And I guess
we can see AMD sixty four is it
for here.
However, it doesn't matter. It could be an
ARM 64, right? If you wanna lower your
cloud spendings, maybe it's smarter to roll with
an ARM 64 instead of AMD sixty four.
And the fact that we use WebAssembly means
we don't have to
do multi arc builds, we don't have to
cross compile things, we can just take the
same workload
and run it on different operating systems on
different architectures.
Alright. One more question for you then. Sure.
That OCIR effect that you have pushed our
registry, if I
have
configuration
which may be sensitive,
is it inside of that OCIR effect?
Is that something people should be aware of
not to push to public
registries if there are sensitive information?
That's a good that's a good question. So
if we go into the source code of
our app,
So
what how how do you provide configuration
data? It does not matter sensitive or not
in the first place to your spin app
is you specify
a variables
block over here where you can say for
example,
log level
default
equals debug something like that. Right?
Then you so once you have defined a
variable that allows the run time to pick
up for example
an environment variable
to read that value.
However you have
to explicitly give your component access to that
variable
testing
sample
dot variables.
Right? And then you can say,
hey, take this from the application
variables. Right. So simple interpolation
syntax over here.
So now let's say you wanna have connection
string
over there.
Obviously you could specify it over here but
then it would be part of the OCR
artifact.
So there is and now I
hope it is secure
secure
true and
we can test if that's the right one.
Okay.
Let's say that. Right. And being
able to use interpolation syntax over here allows
you to do things like for example,
Redis
something like that. Right? If you want to
combine
multiple
application variables into a single
value.
So
I think it is either secure or sensitive.
Let's try spin
up. I don't have to build. Okay, it's
secret.
Secret.
There we go.
Yeah. This is Okay. Then secret. Okay. So
if you push your app to Kubernetes or
if you push your app to as an
OCR artifact somewhere. Right.
Obviously,
the default values specified or hard coded over
here
are part of that one layer in that
OCR artifact.
The other values
are
read
when the application is bootstrap.
Right? And that means we have to load
them from somewhere. And from somewhere could be
a Kubernetes
config map, a Kubernetes secret. It could be
a HashiCorp Vault instance and so on and
so forth. So there are different
like
configuration
data providers
supported by SPIN that
you can integrate to load those values
instead of
hard coding them as I did with the
lock level which I could overwrite obviously.
Or you know to you know bring the
connection
string maybe from
a HashiCorp Vault which is like
a way more
realistic
data
storage for sensitive data than an environment variable
or a ConfigMap.
Yeah. Nice. So that's
the way how you could prevent
yourself from leaking sensitive information
in the first place.
But still, I mean, even if your workload
does not require a sensitive configuration data, it's
still it is still your IP. Right?
So you obviously
can use things like spin
OCI
login or spin
registry
isn't they're an alias, right, for registry.
OCI
is an alias for the registry command
and there is an login command
that you can use to authenticate
against
your
protected
OCR registry
before pushing there.
Awesome.
Love it.
Alright. Anything else you want to show us
or can I move us back over to
big face mode?
Let's move back to the face mode.
Alright. That was that was awesome. Such a
good demo. Thank you for, you know, taking
almost ninety minutes out of your day to
set and guide us through that. I love
the trajectory of where Vermeion and Spin are
going,
being able to deploy this to the Akamai
network. I think it's an absolute game changer
for people that need to write performing applications
for our customers and users around the world.
And I'm very excited to ship some of
my own stuff this way as well. I've
got a lot on my to do list
now.
Awesome. Yeah.
From my point of view, thanks again for
having me here at Rawkode. It was an
absolute blast to
present and, you know, talk about Fermin Walls
and Functions. And,
yeah, as I as I said
at the beginning, it is public it is
a preview and we
if you wanna play explore it, you wanna
run something there,
just
sign up to get access.
We are happy to let people in and
we are listening for feedback. So there is
a feedback command in the CLI.
Just let us know
what you think about Alright.
Well, thank you for your time. To everyone
that watched, enjoy it, and thank you for
watching, and we'll see you all next time.
Have a great day. Thank you. Bye bye.
Rawkode Hit subscribe so you won't miss a
beat. More livestream tutorials can't be beat. Keep
coding, keep learning. It's the Rawkode way. We'll
catch you next time.